PROFESSOR: So I'm going to do
today this identical particles.
We'll continue with
identical particles.
We'll get almost to the
resolution of the issue
of exchange degeneracy.
In order to do this
identical particles properly,
you have to do a bit of
group theory or understanding
what permutation
operators are well.
So it allows you to think about
these matters more clearly.
So that's what we
have to do today.
So let me review.
So we were doing
identical particles.
And we spoke of
exchange degeneracy.
We had, say, for the
state of two spins--
identical spins-- we said could
be represented by this state
or by this state in which
you exchange the pluses
and minuses.
So the problem of
exchange degeneracy
is that, for
identical particles,
you would almost say that these
two states are equivalent.
One particle is in plus
1 particle, is in minus.
They're identical.
So you cannot tell whether
it's the first or the second.
So you would say these
two states are equivalent.
But we saw that that
leads to a contradiction.
If these two states
are equivalent,
any linear superposition of
them should be equivalent.
And then when we
ask the question
of the probability of
finding these states
in a particular state that was
along the x direction-- both
spins along the x
direction-- we found
that it depended on what linear
combination you took here.
So it's just not consistent
with the principles
of quantum mechanics
to say that these two
states are equivalent.
So they're not.
And we better understand how
we can solve this problem.
Now, I think the solution, in
a sense, you've heard before.
And you know how
you're supposed to work
with identical particles.
But I think going
through this in detail
and seeing what is the structure
of operators and Hilbert spaces
that leads to that
solution or why
that solution is the unique
solution to this problem,
it's interesting.
So we begin with
permutation operators.
Operators.
So we consider a
two-particle system.
We'll begin with two particles.
And then we'll eventually
generalize to n particles.
We'll do everything for
two particles first.
So the particles, they will
live on a vector space, V,
each one so that the set of two
particles lives on V tensor V.
So each particle has a
set of possible states
that are the vectors in V.
And the two particles have
a set of possible states that
are the vectors in V tensor V.
Now, for the moment, whether
they're identical or not
identical will play no role.
It will play no role
throughout this lecture,
where we understand those
operators in Hilbert spaces.
So it will not matter.
So the particles may
be distinguishable,
may not be distinguishable.
And we will write states here
in V tensor V, based as states,
for example, as ui1 tensor u2--
I'm sorry, uj2.
So with little i and
little j, they're
noting different integers.
Those are different
basis vectors.
And this is a set of basis
vectors in V tensor V--
so basis vectors
for all i and j.
Now, sometimes we
get a little lazy,
and we stop writing the 1 and 2.
And we write it as ui tensor uj.
Or even we can get more
lazy and just write ui uj.
So if we do that, you
should know you really
mean this whole thing.
So is a permutation operator?
It's a linear operator that does
some funny thing on the state.
So let's look into it.
So a permutation operator, P2,1
That's a name I will give it.
P2,1 is a linear operator
acting on the space V tensor V--
so linear operator.
And this is called the
permutation operator.
So to know what this
permutation operator is,
you need to know how it
acts on a basis state.
So let's put one of these
basis states, ui1 tensor uj2.
And this permutation
operator, you just
need to know how it
acts in the basis state.
That's the safest way
always to know that you
have a linear operator.
If you know how it
acts on a basis state,
then on any sum of basis states,
you know, because it's linear.
On the other hand, if
somebody tells you,
this operator does
this to all vectors--
something-- maybe it's
not a linear operator.
It may be a more
complicated thing.
So here, what it
will do, it will
put the state that was
in 2 in position 1,
and put the state that
was in 1 in position 2.
So it will take
you j1 tensor ui2.
So the state in 2--
this first thing that
says that the state in 2--
should be put in position 1.
So the j label--
it was uj.
Now it's in position 1.
And the state that was in
1 should go to position 2.
The one thing we never
do is flip these things.
The first particle goes
before the second particle.
That's our order of things.
But the state has moved.
OK.
So this is the prescription
of what this does.
And then you realize
already one property--
that P2,1, if you let
it act twice in a state,
it will flip the
ij the first time.
And it will flip them
again the second time.
So this is the unit operator.
So it's inverse.
So that's a nice thing.
Now, perhaps a
little less obvious,
but kind of still simple,
is that P2,1 is Hermition.
How do you check that an
operator is Hermition?
An operator, M, is hermission if
you have, for example, M alpha
beta is equal to alpha and beta.
The M operator moves
from this position
to the other with an M dagger.
But if M is Hermition,
it will work like that.
So let's try this with
the operator P2,1.
So we'll try a P2,1
on the state alpha,
and then [INAUDIBLE]
with a state beta.
So we need a number of letters.
So let's do it here.
P2,1 on a state alpha,
which will be ui1 uj2,
[INAUDIBLE] with a
state beta uk1 ul2.
OK.
Here it is.
P2,1 acting on
some state, alpha,
[INAUDIBLE] with a state beta.
We'll evaluate it.
Well, we can never write
it quickly, I think.
This flips the j and
i so the j is now
on the first particle and the
case in the first particle.
So the inner product, assuming
this is an orthonormal basis,
is just delta jk.
And here, this operator moves
the i label to position 2.
And here you have
an l in position 2.
Therefore, it's a delta il.
On the other hand, we can
calculate this ui1 uj2,
and now put the P2,1
operator here between the uk1
and the ul2.
This time you flip the k
and l, so the l ends up
being the first Hilbert
space, where there's an i.
So you get delta li.
And the key, ends up
in the second Hilbert
space, where you have a j here.
So you have a j with a k.
And these two are the same.
And intuition-- of course, I've
written all these equations.
But intuition is, if you
have an inner product--
this chronicle delta sign--
you exchange two here.
The result is the same as
if you exchange two here.
It will do the same thing.
So it's a Hermitian operator.
So operator P2,1 is Hermitian.
That means that the
relation P2,1 P2,1 equal 1.
Since this is Hermitian--
this P2,1 dagger--
P2,1 equal 1.
So we learn that also
the operator is unitary.
P2,1 is unitary.
That's nice, because
that means that could
be a symmetry in
quantum mechanics.
Operators in quantum
mechanics that
preserve the norm of
states can be symmetries.
And P2,1 is unitary.
OK.
So we have our operator P2,1.
Let's do things with it.
So we can define two
things with P2,1.
Define this operator, S,
which will be 1/2 1 plus P2,1,
and the operator, A,
which is 1/2 1 minus P2,1.
And here comes the claim.
These two operators are
orthogonal projectors.
They're orthogonal projectors.
Projectors.
So let's review what that means.
So basically, let me
say what it means.
An operator is an
orthogonal projector.
The test is that the operator
squared is equal to itself.
That's the name of a projector.
And the other thing is
that it must be Hermitian.
These two things must
happen for something
to be an orthogonal projector.
Basically, what does it mean
to be an orthogonal projector?
It's an operator that
projects to some space.
So an operator has
a set of states
that are in its image in
the range of the operator.
That's what it projects into.
And it has a null space--
the things that are
killed by the projector.
A projector has precisely
that kind of thing.
So the thing that makes it an
orthogonal projector is that
the range of the projector--
the vectors that you get--
are orthogonal to
the vectors that
are killed by the projector.
The whole vector space
splits into two parts--
what do you get from the
projector and the rest.
And the rest is things that
are killed by the projector.
And they're orthogonal to it.
So let me say it here.
A projector P sub U to U
subset of V is orthogonal--
so this is 805 type stuff--
if the vector space
can be written
as the null space of PU.
Plus the range of
PU with null or PU
perpendicular, or
orthogonal, to range of PU.
So this is the definition
of an orthogonal projector.
And here is, of
course, a simple claim.
A Hermitian operator, P such
that P squared is equal to P,
is an orthogonal projector.
Projector.
OK.
So that's second claim.
So let's see again.
What we want to show is
that these are projectors,
and they're
orthogonal projectors.
And this is what it means.
But practically speaking,
all we have to do
is check that this
operator satisfies
this and our Hermitian.
That's all you need to do.
Let me explain why
this is the case.
So whenever you have--
let's do a little proof.
So if you have a
vector, a vector
can be written as the projector
times the vector plus 1
minus the projector
acting on the vector.
This-- the projector
on the vector--
is in the range of P,
because the range of P
are the vectors obtained
by acting with P. Moreover,
this is in the null of P. Why?
Because P kills these vectors.
How do you check that?
P, acting on that vector--
P with this is P. But P squared
is equal to P. So you get 0.
So here it is.
The vector space decomposes into
the range of P plus the null
of P. So that's the first claim
for a orthogonal projector.
The second claim is that
these are orthogonal.
So if I take PV--
something in the range of P--
and 1 minus PV tilde--
something in the
null space of P--
this should be orthogonal.
And this is clear,
because I can move now
this operator to the other side.
And it will be V P
dagger 1 minus P V tilde.
And since P is Hermitian--
that's where you use that P is
Hermitian--
this is V P1 minus P V tilde.
And that's equal to 0, because
P times 1 minus P already is 0.
So OK.
These are our conditions.
Orthogonal projectors
are very nice.
These are the
really good things.
You have a projector that
decomposes into two parts,
just by having P
squared equal P.
But to have orthogonal, you
need that they'd be Hermitian.
So what is our situation
with those operators?
They are Hermitian.
So S and A are Hermitian,
because one is Hermitian,
and P2,1 is Hermitian.
So the operators are Hermitian.
And they are projectors,
because, well, you check them.
You multiply them by themselves.
So we can do the two
of them simultaneously.
This is with a plus sign.
That's S. With a
minus sign, it's A.
So we need to show that
S squared is equal to S
and A squared is equal to A.
So here we have both cases.
So the product is 1/4,
then plus minus 2 P2,1,
and then the product of these
operators with themselves.
Plus minus and plus minus
always gives you a plus.
And P2,1 times P2,1, we
showed that that's equal to 1.
So happily, this
1 and 1 give a 2.
There's another 2.
Divides here-- this is
1/2 1 plus minus P2,1.
So that's what we wanted
to show with a top sign,
S times S is equal to
S, with a bottom sign,
A times A is equal to A.